Hello world.
It's Saroj and let's visualize a Dataset
of eating habits to see what we can
learn from it, shall we?
There's some really hard
scientific questions out there.
Are we alone in the universe? What is
consciousness? What is dark matter?
Really questions like these have
multimillion dollar payouts and have been
troubling scientists for hundreds
of years, but guess what?
We very likely already
have the answers to them.
The problem is that they aren't in
plain sight. They're hidden in data.
The former leader of the u s government
effort to sequence the human genome said
that it took several years of effort,
a huge team of researchers and $50
million to find the gene responsible for
cystic fibrosis and 89 but
that same projects could
now be accomplished in a few
days by a good Grad students.
You watching this right now? Yes,
you can make a Nobel worthy
breakthrough with just your laptop.
The data you need is freely available.
You just have to discover the
hidden relationships in it.
The field of dimensionality reduction
is all about discovering nonlinear
nonlocal relationships in data that are
not obvious and the original feature
space. If we reduce the number
of dimensions and some data,
we can visualize it because a projection
in two or three d space can be plotted
really easily unless you use PHP training.
A model on a dataset with many dimensions
usually requires vast time and space
complexity.
It also often leads to overfitting.
Not all the features we have available
to us are relevant to our problem.
If we reduced the dimensions,
we can reduce the noise,
the unnecessary parts of the data and
find those that are surprisingly very
closely related and once in a smaller
sub space we can more easily apply simple
learning algorithms to it.
We can divide dimensionality
reduction into two different topics.
Feature selection and feature extraction
selection is all about finding the most
relevant features to a problem.
It can be based on our intuition as in
which features do we think would be the
most relevant or we could let a model
one of the best features by itself.
Extraction means finding new features.
After transforming the data from a high
dimensional space to a lower dimensional
space,
we'll perform the ladder using a technique
called principle component analysis.
Our dataset is going to be a record of
the 17 types of food that the average
person consumes per week
for every country in the UK.
So we've got 17 features slash.
Dimensions.
Let's see what kind of insights
we can get from this data.
PCA transforms variables into a new
set of variables which are a linear
combination of the original variables.
These new variables are known
as principal components.
PCA is an orthogonal linear transformation
that transforms data to a new
coordinate system such that the greatest
variance by some projection of the data
locked on the first principal component.
The second greatest variance on
the second component and so on,
the variance is the measure
of how spread out the data is.
If I were to measure the variance of the
height of a team of basketball players,
it would be pretty low,
but if I added a group of primary
school children to the mix,
the variance would be pretty high.
Our first step is to standardize the data.
PCA is a variance maximizing exercise.
It projects the original data onto a
direction which maximizes variance.
If we were to graph a small data set
that shows the amount of variance for the
different principal components,
it will seem like only one component
explains all the variants in the data like
Putin at the g 20 summit,
but if we standardize the data first,
then we'll see that the other components
do indeed contribute to the variance as
well.
Standardizing means putting the
data on the same unit scale for us,
that would be grams for everything,
not a combination of kilograms and grams.
That means the data should have a
mean of zero and a variance of one.
Amit is just the average value
of all axes in the set x,
which we can find by dividing the sum
of all the data points by the number of
them.
The way we calculate variance is by
computing the standard deviation squared.
The standard deviation is the square root
of the average distance of data points
to the mean.
It's used to tell how measurements for
a group are spread out from the me.
Once our data is standardized, we're
going to perform. I get it. Decomposition.
So if your mama is so fat,
she's not embeddable and three space
I can Paris will help fix that.
I again is a German word that roughly
translates to characteristic and in linear
Algebra and I can vector is a vector that
doesn't change its direction under the
associated linear transformation.
Decompose,
decompose my sole
value parity, compose my soul. Another
way of putting it is that if we have
a non zero Vector v then it's an
eigenvector of a square matrix.
A if a is a scalar multiple of the,
so the land of scalar is an eigenvalue
or characteristic value associated with
the eigenvector.
V Eigen values are the
coefficients attached to eigen
vectors that give the axes
magnitude.
If we had a sheer mapping and displaced
every point in a fixed direction,
notice how the Red Arrow changes
direction, but the Blue Arrow doesn't.
The Blue Arrow is the eigen vector of
the mapping because it doesn't change
direction and its length is
unchanged. It's eigenvalue. It's one.
Both terms are important in many fields,
especially physics,
since they can help measure the stability
of rotating bodies and oscillations,
fiber rating systems.
Many problems can be modeled with linear
transformations and I can vectors get
very simple solutions.
Okay,
okay.
Interventions.
Why set her reasons?
PCA's deterministic. Yes,
it so the correct fences and it
makes data portable on a two d graph,
which so we could even painted ourselves.
I'm dawn to paying some pretty data.
What's data by cameras?
If we had a system of linear
differential equations, for example,
to measure how the growth of population
of two species x and y affect one
another,
like if one is a Predator of another,
solving this system
directly is complicated,
but if we could introduce
two new variables, Z and w,
which depends linearly on x,
we can decouple the system.
So instead we are dealing with
two independent functions.
The eigenvectors and eigenvalues for
this matrix of coefficients do just this.
They decoupled the ways in which a linear
transformation acts into a number of
independent actions along separate
directions that can be dealt with
independently. So we'll need to
construct a covariance matrix.
Then we'll perform.
I can decompensation on that Matrix.
A Matrix is just a table of values.
A covariance matrix is symmetric,
so the table has the same heading across
the top as it does along the sides.
It describes the variants of the data
and the covariants among variables.
Covariants is a measure of
how two variables change
with respect to each other.
It's positive when variables show
similar behavior and negative. Otherwise,
PCA tries to draw straight lines
through data like linear regression.
Each straight line is
a principal component,
a relationship between an
independent and dependent variable.
The number of principal components equals
the number of dimensions in the data
and PCA's job is to prioritize them.
If two variables change together,
it's very likely because one is acting
on the other or they're both subject to
that same hidden force.
Performing Eigen decomposition on our
covariance matrix helps us find the hidden
forces at work in our data.
Since we can't eyeball inter variable
relationships in high dimensional space.
When calculating the covariance Matrix,
the mean vector that's used to help do
so is one where each value represents a
sample mean of a feature column in the
Dataset. Once we have our eigen pairs,
we'll want to select the
principle components.
We need to decide which ones can be
dropped and that's where our eigen values
come in. We'll rank the
eigenvalues from highest to lowest,
the lowest ones bear the least info about
the distribution of the data so we can
drop a number of them like they're cold.
Next,
we'll construct a projection matrix.
This is just the Matrix of our
concatenated top K eigen vectors.
We can choose how many dimensions we
want for our sub space by choosing that
amount of Eigen vectors to construct our
d by k dimensional eigen vector matrix
w.
Lastly,
we'll use this projection
matrix to transform our
samples onto the subspace via
a simple dot product operation.
If we project our data
onto one dimensional space,
then we can already see
something interesting.
Notice how Northern Ireland is
a major outlier. It makes sense.
According to the data.
The Northern Irish consume
way more potatoes in alcohol
and way too few healthy
options. The same thing happens
if we graft both components.
We can see relations between data
points that we wouldn't otherwise.
To summarize,
principal component analysis is a
technique that transforms a dataset onto a
lower dimensional sub space so we can
visualize and find hidden relationships in
it. The principal components are eigen
vectors coupled with eigen values.
They describe the direction in the
original feature space with the greatest
variance in the data and the variance
is a measure of how spread out some data
is. The winter of last week's
coding challenge his own job.
He implemented a self organizing feature,
math for colors and
for handwritten digits.
Really efficient code and well documented.
Great job.
Oh and wizard of the week and the runner
up is Hamas shake who developed a super
detailed Jupiter notebook on self
organizing maps for class size effects on
students.
This week's coding challenge is to perform
PCA from scratch on a Dataset of your
choice posts or get hub
link in the comments,
and I'll give the winners
a shout out next week.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to release a music video,
so thanks for watching.